so it's been a while that a lot of
people ask me that how to prepare for
our tea jam and we cannot have good
concepts so how do I prepare for IIT jab
which topics I should read which topics
I should not read or don't put more
stress on that so how to prepare for
that and I have only three months left
can I even party jam and etc etc so
that's why I thought I should make a
video on what are the important topics
that you should read and cannot ignore
for I teach and biotechnology so stay
tuned till the end of the video so
probably this is you who want to crack
the I teach my technology but what
happens is as days goes by and time goes
by you feel frustrated and you just
don't plan your stuff properly so first
thing that comes in your mind is where
to start and what to read and ultimately
this is the consequence that so you
think it is too much to read but you
should plan it properly first step first
first step you have to analyze the push
paper of previous year second identify
the frequently asked topics and spend
70% of your effort to study all the
topics which are frequently asked and
other things you can like spend less
time and just touch those topics briefly
two important aspect is use audio visual
cues which would help your learning and
boost your learning process several
times and solve questions and
continuously do self assessments that
would help you to improve your skills so
first question is how much time do I
spend on each topic and definitely you
need to plan the time distribution so
here is the overall statistics of all
the biology topics that are asked in I
teach em biotechnology exam so among
that you will see there are at least
nine such topics that are very very
important including biochemistry cell
biology NMR
biology immunology microbiology
physiology and cell signaling so if you
clearly see that topics like NMR topics
like cell signaling these from these
sections there are not too much
questions that are asked they asked
little questions from that like every
year consistently two or three questions
but every year they do ask questions
from that and all these questions are
mostly elementary so solving that
questions continuously can give you
consistent number other topics for
example biochemistry cell biology they
asked quite a lot of questions but there
are hard questions and among them so the
chances are that you won't be able to
answer a bio chemistry question even
though you spend a huge amount of your
preparation time to biochemistry but if
you tactically handle this and do NMR
first and since cell signaling first
though the weight is less but you have
that short number and I have a whole
playlist for an emergency cooling etc
for these topics how to tackle those
questions because animal cells like the
immunology these part of questions are
not these these type of questions are
not generally taught in the course and
even if it is taught it is taught in the
last minute so the preparation for these
thing is poor think about it one of your
friend may not answer an NMR question
but can answer the biochemistry question
so you have to play the game in a
different way so you have to like school
in the uncommon topics that other people
cannot school that would give you an
advantage point so now just let's look
at how do we plan our topics among all
these topics there are specific hotspot
topics which are frequently asked and I
have listed them for example so if we
plan cell biology one of the interesting
part is cell signaling and they always
ask like two to three questions every
year and cell signaling coverage is low
and even inside cell signaling special
focus goes on g-protein coupled receptor
signaling and some aspects of it
after that Sayle division is the most
important one and apart from these two
topics cell organelles and other
residual topics comprise the whole bit
whose coverage is pretty huge but at the
same time the type of questions are
unpredictable and sometimes they are
even difficult questions so spending
more time on cell signaling and cell
deviation and cell cycle regulation is
one of the most clever way to handle it
now coming to biochemistry frequently
asked topics are structures of protein
and nucleic acid and sometimes sugar as
well so also structure and functions of
vitamins so vitamins are one of the
favorite topics of our Jam and every
year people ask question from this
vitamin section also enzyme ology is
another important topic but everywhere
easy questions are asked from enzyme
ology which are good and scoring apart
from that metabolism is there whose
coverage is huge
but the chances that you would answer a
metabolic question is always do so it's
better to give time and metabolism but
still bird's-eye view of metabolism and
touching all the topics of metabolism
would be a clever way but among
metabolism topics like glycogenesis
gluconeogenesis glycolysis and fatty
acid breakdown these topics are the
favorite for IIT Jen now coming to
Fleming's molecular biology 1 if you're
in molecular biology central dogma
like basic truck transcription
translation and replication mechanisms
are important and several enzymes that
are used in this process are frequently
asked year after year and also becoming
in DNA technology
week on restriction enzymes strategies
and PCR techniques these are very very
important from this molecular biology
section there should we focus on Lac
operon and ship operon because at least
one of the question from trip overall
that opera is asked every year and
several techniques in molecular biology
is very important so they frequently ask
a matching type questions when they give
several techniques in
and their usage so that it that is most
easy easy to list an easy to score if
you talk about microbiology it's an
important topic and most of the
questions are asked from the various
aspects of cell structures and
structures and involves specially now
mainly comparison between bacteria and
archaea bacteria cell 1 composition of
the architecture II and you bacteria etc
now apart from that crumb staining
technique the antibiotic mode of action
bacterial toxin etc are one of the
important topics in microbiology section
so if you follow these kind of
distribution and if you can customize
your own distribution based on your own
strengths I would say it xfinity work
and it would help you to save your time
and also prepare efficiently remember
you cannot even if you don't cover
everything but whatever topics you're
covering covered 100% because doing 20%
of all the topics is not going to help
fourth exam rather than you cover 60% of
all the topics but with 100% coverage
that would give you a advantage over
others and you could definitely crack
this exam like anything so if you like
my video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe